Donc, aujourd'hui, nous allons finir la leçon de conclusion.
Et c'est une leçon qui va...
Donc, nous avons vu d'abord la première définition, c'était de voir la crainte de Dieu,
ce à quoi devait ressembler la crainte de Dieu.
Ensuite, nous avons abordé ce à quoi ressemble la crainte de l'homme
et un peu tout ce qui peut s'étendre autour.
Et aujourd'hui, nous allons partir sur un nouveau paradigme.
Donc, on peut dire un ensemble de principes.
C'est-à-dire qu'après que nous ayons discerné qu'est-ce qui est attendu,
qu'est-ce que Dieu attend de nous sur notre façon de craindre,
de le craindre et notre façon d'aborder notre relation avec les hommes,
nous allons aussi voir aujourd'hui comment Dieu nous appelle à une nouvelle façon de penser.
Et donc, cette nouvelle façon de penser, ce n'est pas de craindre l'homme,
c'est plutôt d'aimer et servir au lieu de craindre.
C'est d'aimer et servir au lieu de chercher à avoir besoin en craignant.
Donc, d'abord, pour l'introduction, ce que je peux dire,
ce que nous avions déjà vu la dernière fois,
c'est que nous avions réfléchi aux différentes manières
dont nous pouvons lutter contre la peur des hommes
et à la manière de comment considérer,
comment nous pouvons considérer Dieu plus grand que les autres.
Et considérer Dieu comme plus grand que les hommes,
le craindre et cesser de craindre les hommes,
c'est une question qui n'est pas toujours évidente.
En craignant le Seigneur comme il se doit,
nous grandirons dans notre désir et notre capacité d'aimer Dieu et notre prochain.
En réfléchissant à ce que signifie aimer Dieu et notre prochain,
j'encourage chacun de nous à réfléchir dès maintenant
à des situations ou à des personnes que nous avons eu tendance à craindre.
D'ailleurs, c'est ce que nous avions fait un moment,
nous avions réfléchi à cet aspect.
Pendant les cours, nous avions réfléchi à des situations dans notre vie
où nous avions eu à craindre les hommes,
où nous n'avions pas su craindre suffisamment Dieu.
Et notre réflexion aujourd'hui, c'est comment nous pouvons développer notre amour
et notre capacité à ne pas craindre telle relation ou telle situation.
N'oublions pas que grandir dans la crainte du Seigneur
et l'amour des autres ne se fait pas du jour au lendemain.
Ce que nous devrions retenir, c'est que la crainte de l'homme
peut être une tentation permanente.
Et d'ailleurs, même quand nous avions réfléchi à cela,
nous avions vu que même dans le témoignage de beaucoup,
certains allaient témoigner le fait que c'est quelque chose
qui est ancré dans leur vie depuis plusieurs années.
Mais nous avions aussi vu que nous ne devons pas,
nous devons nous délivrer de cette tentation de craindre l'homme
et nous devrions nous efforcer de nous repentir régulièrement
en gardant les yeux fixés sur le Christ,
en étant confiant qu'il achevera l'œuvre qu'il a commencée en nous.
Donc le premier point,
lorsque nous sommes en train de redéfinir notre pensée
vis-à-vis de la crainte de Dieu et vis-à-vis de cette crainte de l'homme,
le premier point, c'est une réorientation vers Dieu,
mais c'est une réorientation qui vient de Dieu.
Donc ça, c'est le premier point.
Nous ne pouvons comprendre ce que signifie aimer les autres
au lieu de les craindre que lorsque nous comprenons
et vivons la réalité de notre relation qui a été changée avec Dieu.
Parce que Dieu nous a aimés, nous le craignons et nous l'aimons.
Parce que Dieu nous a aimés, nous devons aimer les autres.
Nous avons une dette d'amour envers les autres.
C'est déjà important de préciser, nous avons une dette d'amour envers les autres.
C'est ce que la parole nous signale.
Nous ne sommes pas dans une condition où nous considérons comme une option
de pouvoir aimer les autres.
Nous avons besoin des autres,
mais nous n'avons pas besoin de quelque chose d'eux.
Nous avons besoin d'eux pour les aimer.
Le principe biblique, c'est que nous avons besoin des autres pour les aimer.
Nous lirons 1 Jean 4.
Donc je peux vous donner la référence.
C'est 1 Jean 4 du verset 7 au verset 12.
C'est l'un des textes essentiels pour comprendre l'amour de Dieu envers nous,
notre amour pour Dieu,
et la nécessité de notre amour envers les autres,
et notre rapport à la peur.
Donc si, en lisant ce passage,
nous pourrons réfléchir à l'exemple qui nous est donné,
à cet exemple dans la façon dont Jean décrit l'amour de Dieu pour nous,
à l'exemple qui nous donne pour réfléchir à la manière d'aimer les autres.
Il est important de remarquer,
il est important de comprendre comment Dieu a agi envers nous
pour entretenir de bonnes relations avec les autres.
C'est-à-dire, quand nous voyons ce que Dieu a fait envers nous,
nous comprenons aussi comment nous pouvons avoir de meilleures relations avec les autres.
Donc je lis 1 Jean 4 du verset 7 au verset 12 qui nous dit,
« Bien-aimés, aimons-nous les uns les autres,
car l'amour vient de Dieu,
et quiconque aime est né de Dieu et connaît Dieu.
Celui qui n'aime pas n'a pas connu Dieu, car Dieu est amour.
L'amour de Dieu a été manifesté envers nous
en ce que Dieu a envoyé son Fils unique dans le monde,
afin que nous vivions par lui.
Et cet amour consiste non pas en ce que nous avons aimé Dieu,
mais en ce qu'il nous a aimés
et a envoyé son Fils comme victime expiatoire pour nos péchés.
Bien-aimés, si Dieu nous a ainsi aimés,
nous devons aussi nous aimer les uns les autres.
Personne n'a jamais vu Dieu.
Si nous nous aimons les uns les autres,
Dieu demeure en nous et son amour est parfait en nous. »
Qu'est-ce que Jean est en train de nous signifier par là ?
L'amour de Dieu a eu un prix.
Dieu a envoyé Jésus pour mourir sur la croix.
Par l'incarnation de Christ et son œuvre expiatoire,
Jésus-Christ nous offre l'exemple ultime de celui qui a aimé son prochain
de manière souvent coûteuse.
C'était une manière coûteuse,
c'était une manière difficile,
c'était une manière douloureuse.
Et donc, en réfléchissant à ce que signifie aimer son prochain
au lieu de le craindre,
nous devons d'abord apprendre à comprendre l'amour de Dieu.
Vous voyez, là nous redéfinissons,
on va revenir là-dessus.
« Quand nous nous tournons vers Dieu,
nous reconnaissons son choix gracieux de nous aimer. »
Quand nous nous tournons vers Dieu,
ça ne va pas renforcer notre estime de soi,
mais ça va détruire notre orgueil.
Je lis dans Ephésiens 1, chapitre 1, versets 5 à 6,
Paul dit, donc il parle de Dieu,
« Il nous a prédestinés à être ses enfants d'adoption par Jésus-Christ
selon le dessein de sa volonté,
à la louange de sa grâce glorieuse
dont il nous a bénis dans le bien-aimé. »
Paul dit plus tard qu'en raison de l'œuvre gracieuse de Dieu
dans l'élection et l'octroi de la foi,
nous n'avons plus de quoi nous vanter.
Nous n'avons pas à nous vanter,
nous devons toujours considérer que tout n'est que grâce pour nous.
Et ça nous aide aussi à comprendre
pourquoi nous avons alors une dette d'amour envers les autres.
« Si Dieu a agi ainsi envers nous,
comment pourrions-nous agir autrement
qu'avec amour envers les autres ? »
« Si Dieu nous a déjà acceptés en Christ,
pourquoi nous laissons-nous encore asservir
par le désir d'être acceptés par les autres ? »
Donc là, nous avions aussi parlé par rapport à l'estime de soi,
vous pouvez réécouter le cours aussi,
de comment nous devons concevoir l'estime de soi
selon un point de vue biblique.
Avec cette réorientation,
donc le fait de réorienter vers Dieu,
« Nous ne cherchons plus à être acceptés par les autres,
mais nous cherchons à aimer les autres
de telle manière qu'ils soient orientés vers l'acceptation
que seul le Christ peut trouver, peut donner. »
Enfin, en nous réorientant vers Dieu,
nous pouvons nous réjouir en ce Dieu
qui nous a acceptés, protégés et couverts.
Je vais beaucoup citer Ed Welch
parce qu'à un moment, une bonne partie de cette étude
a été basée sur le livre qu'il a écrit.
Quand il parle de le titre,
je n'ai plus le titre en anglais,
mais ça veut dire à un moment,
« Les hommes grands et un Dieu petit »,
c'est-à-dire de comprendre
comment les hommes voient l'estime de soi
ou à un moment, ils vont donner plus d'importance
aux hommes qu'à Dieu.
Donc, ce n'est pas le contraire,
il n'est pas en train de dire que Dieu est petit.
Donc, Ed Welch va nous dire, par exemple,
« Dieu nous comble.
Dieu déverse son amour dans nos cœurs
par le Saint-Esprit qu'il nous a donné.
Dieu nous comble de lui-même.
Cela ne nous est accessible
que lorsque nous adoptons la forme
d'une coupe de besoins psychologiques. »
Donc, je parle de la coupe,
je vais aussi expliquer dans ce sens.
« Autrement dit, si nous voulons être comblés
pour nous sentir heureux et mieux dans notre peau,
nous ne serons jamais véritablement submergés
par l'amour de Dieu. »
Là, je reprends l'exemple de la coupe.
« La coupe de nos propres désirs
ne peut jamais absorber le flot de l'amour
et de la bénédiction de Dieu. »
Lorsque cette coupe du « je veux »,
donc la coupe du « je veux » se brise,
elle nous laisse avec les multiples formes
ou identités que Dieu nous a données.
Donc, lorsque il y a ce brisement
où nous considérons un moment
que nous devons baser notre estime de soi
sur la façon dont Dieu nous voit
et non les hommes,
nous comprenons notre rôle de prêtre,
nous comprenons notre rôle d'ambassadeur en Christ,
nous comprenons notre rôle
d'enfant de Dieu et de chrétien.
Il est beaucoup plus sûr et efficace
de nous tourner vers les autres
pour combler notre vide.
Ça, c'est ce que nous pouvons souvent penser.
Et souvent, nous allons...
L'amour que nous désirons,
que nous cherchons chez les hommes,
finalement, c'est un amour
qui ne peut être trouvé qu'en Dieu.
L'amour de Dieu envers nous,
et c'est la conclusion sur ce premier point,
l'amour de Dieu envers nous,
c'est un amour qui est radical.
C'est un amour qui est scandaleux.
D'ailleurs, regardons l'exemple.
Le monde a du mal à accepter le principe
d'aimer son prochain,
d'aimer quelqu'un qui nous a fait du mal.
Le monde n'arrive pas à comprendre ce principe.
L'amour de Dieu est radical,
il est scandaleux,
c'est un amour qui apporte la liberté,
c'est un amour qui transforme,
c'est un amour qui non seulement
change notre relation avec Dieu,
mais aussi notre relation avec les autres.
Le deuxième point,
donc il y a cette réorientation,
c'est-à-dire quand nous devons,
en conclusion,
pour cette crainte de Dieu
et nous détacher de la crainte de l'homme,
le premier point,
c'était de nous réorienter vers Dieu
en prenant la source qui vient de Dieu.
Le deuxième grand point,
c'est de nous réorienter vers les autres,
aimer et servir,
ne pas avoir peur,
et avoir besoin.
Donc si vous vous souvenez,
cet aspect d'avoir besoin,
je ne vais pas rentrer dans les détails,
vous pouvez réécouter,
c'est notre frère Nathanael,
je n'ai plus le...
je crois que c'était la leçon à la suite
de l'estime de soi,
où il parlait justement
de cet aspect d'avoir besoin.
À cause de l'amour coûteux de Dieu envers nous,
nous pouvons prendre de grands risques
dans nos relations avec les autres.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que nous, en tant que chrétiens,
nous sommes tellement enracinés
dans l'amour de Dieu en Christ
que l'acceptation et la probation
ne constituent pas le fondement
sur lequel nous nous appuyons.
Nous n'allons pas nous sentir plus aimés
parce qu'à un moment,
nous avons été acceptés des hommes.
Non.
Nous comprenons au moment
l'amour de Dieu pour nous
et c'est suffisant.
C'est essentiel.
Notre réorientation vers Dieu
nous aide à voir la véritable valeur
et le rôle des autres.
Les autres n'ont pas été créés.
L'homme n'a pas été créé pour être craint,
mais l'homme a été créé pour être aimé.
Cela va à l'encontre
de ce que l'on entend dans notre culture.
Dans notre culture,
on va nous dire un moment,
tu dois d'abord penser à toi,
tu dois avoir tes besoins satisfaits.
Ça, c'est la définition mondaine du succès.
C'est-à-dire,
la définition mondaine du succès
se mesure au nombre de personnes
qui vont te servir.
Et pour nous,
dans notre compréhension,
au contraire,
c'est notre définition du succès,
ce sera de plus en plus
comment nous sommes serviteurs des autres.
En quoi cet aspect de...
cette définition du succès mondaine
est contraire à ce que signifie
ressembler à Christ ?
Quelles sont les différences
entre aimer, servir
et craindre et avoir besoin de quelqu'un ?
Aimer les autres
ne signifie pas nécessairement
être gentil avec eux.
Ça ne signifie pas
se sacrifier pour eux
ou leur dire oui.
Ça, c'est déjà
une mauvaise compréhension à un moment.
Et voilà comment
certaines personnes
sous la manipulation
vont te dire,
si tu m'aimes,
même quand ça va
à l'encontre de la parole,
tu feras telle ou telle chose.
Non, ce n'est pas ça l'amour.
En fait, parfois,
la gentillesse,
le sacrifice
ou le oui
peuvent dissimuler
notre peur de l'homme.
Parfois,
aimer les autres
signifie faire des choses
qu'ils ne percevront pas
immédiatement comme gentils.
Aimer les autres
peut signifier
de dire non.
Aimer les autres
implique,
certes,
des sacrifices.
On va le voir
quand on va
à 1 Corinthiens 13.
Mais le sacrifice seul
n'est pas forcément
synonyme d'amour
et il n'est pas
nécessairement alimenté
par l'amour.
Alors,
peut-être,
vous pouvez ressentir
un désir intense
de donner aux autres
et de vous sacrifier
pour eux,
mais c'est par désir
de les satisfaire
ou de les empêcher
de vous rejeter.
Ça, ça peut être
le cas souvent.
On va beaucoup servir,
on va beaucoup se donner,
on va donner aux autres,
se sacrifier pour eux,
mais dans le but
de ne pas être rejeté.
Peut-être même
que vous êtes en train
de vous sacrifier
et de vous donner
à ceux qui devraient
apprendre à assumer
davantage de responsabilités.
Là encore,
c'est l'exact opposé
d'aimer les autres.
Nous avons besoin
de la sagesse de Dieu
là-dessus
et nous avons besoin
de demander conseil
afin de discerner
la différence.
Souvent,
ce qui peut apparaître
comme un service,
le fait de nous donner
qui apparaît
comme un sacrifice,
va beaucoup venir
avec une crainte de l'homme
par peur du rejet,
par peur même
de ne pas être satisfait
dans certains besoins.
Aimer les autres
ne sera pas facile.
là, je pense que
je ne vous apprends rien.
Welch dit
aimer les autres
rend la vie
moins confortable.
Cela signifie
que je renonce
à mes propres occupations
par exemple
un samedi matin
pour aider un voisin.
Donc là,
on va parler par exemple
d'un déménagement à venir.
Cela signifie
que je suis blessé
quand quelqu'un déménage.
Cela signifie
que des gens restent
chez nous
alors que je préférerais
être entouré
uniquement
de ma famille proche.
c'est à peu près
ce que la parole de Dieu
va nous demander.
Juste au moment
où nous pensons
l'avoir adapté
au confort,
à notre confort,
le fait de nous sacrifier
va tout bouleverser.
La parole de Dieu
va nous dire
un moment
que aimer les autres
c'est aimer les autres
de la même manière
que Dieu nous a aimés.
Aimer les autres
c'est aimer les autres
c'est les aimer
de la même manière
que Dieu nous a aimés.
Et dans ce point-là
nous allons voir
c'est pas
là c'est
c'est
un
on va dire
le premier point
de ce grand deux
c'est une question
c'est un peu
une question aussi
que des disciples
à un moment
des personnes
qui étaient avec
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
pouvaient avoir posé
qui devons-nous
aimer et servir ?
La parole de Dieu
va nous donner
plusieurs catégories
de personnes.
La première personne
le premier être
que nous devons
aimer et servir
c'est Dieu.
Nous avons déjà
considéré
notre réorientation
vers Dieu.
Nous pouvons maintenant
faire ce que
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
nous dit dans
Matthieu 22
37 à 38
Jean j'ai noté
les références
comme ça après
il lui dit
tu aimeras le Seigneur
ton Dieu
de tout ton cœur
de toute ton âme
et de toute ta pensée
c'est le premier
et le grand commandement.
Contrairement
à la culture
laïque
dans laquelle
nous vivons
on va même dire
cette culture
laïque
est très
très centrée
sur la psychologie
mondaine
contrairement à cette culture
dans laquelle
nous vivons
qui ignore
toute orientation
vers Dieu
et qui va plutôt
privilégier
l'orientation
vers l'intérieur
si vous vous souvenez
à un moment
on avait parlé
que ça va être
au niveau
de la psychologie
on va toujours te dire
tu dois d'abord
rechercher
ce qui est bien
pour toi
c'est pas ce que
la Bible nous dit
et ensuite
ce qui est bien
pour toi
et ensuite
tu verras
ce que tu peux
donner aux autres
ce n'est pas ce que
l'écriture nous dit
l'orientation
laïque
va nous dire
connais-toi toi-même
et sois fidèle
à toi-même
mais la parole
de Dieu
nous montre
une autre voie
la parole de Dieu
nous dit
connais ton Dieu
connais et aime ton prochain
alors seulement
tu sauras vraiment
ce que signifie
se connaître soi-même
chaque fois
on voit toujours
que c'est l'inverse
on va dire
à un moment
aime-toi toi-même
sois toi-même
et ensuite
tu pourras maintenant
t'affirmer devant les autres
la Bible nous dit
à un moment
connais ton Dieu
connais et aime ton prochain
et alors
tu vas te connaître
toi-même
donc le premier être
à qui nous devons
de l'amour
et du service
c'est Dieu
la deuxième catégorie
ce sont
nos ennemis
pour être caractérisés
comme ceux
qui nous veulent du mal
ou qui nous ont fait du mal
par le passé
dans Luc 6
27 à 33
voilà ce que nous dit
la parole
c'est un des passages
les plus difficiles
pour beaucoup d'entre nous
par rapport à certaines
souffrances
au mal
que nous avons pu vivre
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ dit
mais je vous dis
à vous qui m'écoutez
aimez vos ennemis
faites du bien
à ceux qui vous haïssent
bénissez ceux
qui vous maudissent
priez pour ceux
qui vous maltraitent
à celui qui te frappe
sous la joue
présente aussi l'autre
et à celui qui te prend
ton manteau
ne refuse pas
non plus ta tunique
donne à quiconque
te demande
et ne réclame pas ton bien
à celui qui le prend
et comme vous voudriez
que les autres
vous fassent
faites-le pour eux
si vous aimez
ceux qui vous aiment
quel avantage
cela vous sert-il
car même les pécheurs
aiment ceux
qui les aiment
et si vous faites
du bien
à ceux
qui vous font du bien
quel avantage
cela vous sert-il
car même les pécheurs
font de même
quand nous lisons ça
et nous avions parlé
de ça
nous voyons que c'est
une exigence élevée
et ce que nous avions dit
c'est que si quelqu'un
n'a pas eu un cœur
régénéré par Dieu
il n'est pas capable
d'obéir à ce commandement
c'est un commandement
ce commandement
est réservé
à ceux
qui ont eu leur cœur
changé par Dieu
aimer ses ennemis
c'est quelque chose
de douloureux
aimer ses ennemis
ça peut même être
quelque chose
d'effrayant
et pourtant si nous obéissons
au Seigneur Jésus Christ
et que nous aimons
comme il nous a commandé
si nous aimons
les autres
au lieu de les craindre
alors
nous allons
étendre cet amour
même à ceux
qui sont contre nous
un autre argument
que Ed Welch
donc
comme je vous ai dit
en tire beaucoup
de son livre
aussi pour la
constitution du cours
il va dire
un moment
quand il donne
un excellent argument
pour aimer
ses ennemis
il va dire
face à nos ennemis
si nous ne savons pas
quoi dire
ou comment réagir
nous devrions nous tourner
directement vers les psaumes
lorsque nous sommes
enclins à prendre
les choses en main
les psaumes nous apprennent
à faire confiance à Dieu
lorsque nous voulons
nous protéger
de la douleur
ils nous apprennent
à faire confiance à Dieu
au lieu de promettre
de ne plus jamais
nous rapprocher d'autrui
parce que c'est souvent
ce que produit la blessure
on va se dire
un moment
on ne va plus aimer
les personnes
on va couper les ponts
on va ceci
non
au lieu de promettre
de ne plus jamais
nous approcher
d'autrui
nous apprenons
à faire confiance
à Dieu
au lieu d'anéantir
l'espoir
les psaumes
nous apprennent
à faire confiance
à Dieu
dans les psaumes
la mission de David
était la gloire de Dieu
et non sa propre
justification
et là encore
il précise
ce que c'est
d'aimer
ses ennemis
Dieu
dit
que nous devons
traiter nos ennemis
de la même manière
que nous traitons
nos amis
et notre famille
c'est ce que la parole
de Dieu dit
c'est très difficile
quand nous sommes même
en train d'entendre ça
pour aimer ainsi
nous avons besoin
de puissance
et de discernement
nous avons besoin
de puissance
parce que nous sommes
incapables d'aimer
comme le Christ
nous a aimés
nous avons besoin
de discernement
parce qu'il est parfois
difficile de savoir
quelle forme
l'amour doit prendre
dans ce genre de cas aussi
par conséquent
chaque fois que nous avons
conscience
d'avoir des personnes
qui peuvent
constituer une sorte
d'ennemi
le chrétien n'est pas
censé avoir des ennemis
mais nous en avons
nous devrions demander
conseil à l'église
afin de discerner
comment exprimer
cet amour
et d'ailleurs
ça c'est déjà arrivé
plusieurs fois
qu'il y ait des frères et soeurs
qu'il y ait des problèmes
dans leur famille
ou des collègues
difficiles et autres
et qui sont venus
demander conseil
aux frères et soeurs
pour savoir
comment ils peuvent
traiter cela
c'est un point important
l'amour pour ses ennemis
peut se traduire
différemment
de l'amour pour ses amis
l'amour pour un ennemi
peut impliquer
alors ça c'est
de l'amour
l'amour pour un ennemi
peut impliquer
de le livrer
aux autorités terrestres
s'il a enfreint la loi
ça c'est très facile
à faire
un moment pour certains
d'entre nous
ou de nous séparer
physiquement
pour éviter
de nouveaux dommages
ça aussi c'est tout à fait
normal
si nous avons du mal
à comprendre
ce que devrait être
l'amour pour nos ennemis
nous pouvons aussi en parler
aux anciens de l'église
ou à des frères
et soeurs en crise
dans la foi
qui sont plus sages
l'amour
une troisième catégorie
pour les incroyants
et là encore
c'est plus pertinent
encore par rapport
à ce que nous sommes
en train de vivre
depuis quelques jours
les non-croyants
pourraient appartenir
à plusieurs de ces catégories
je pense qu'il est important
de réfléchir un instant
à la manière
d'aimer les perdus
les perdus
nous devons prier pour eux
nous devons être prêts
à leur parler
de l'espérance
qui est en nous
nous devons être prévenants
envers eux
et nous ne devons pas
les traiter
comme des projets
de l'évangile
ils ne sont pas
dans un programme
non
nous devons apprendre
à aimer
l'incroyant
nous ne sommes pas juste là
pour remplir un programme
d'évangélisation
nous sommes d'abord là
pour créer une relation
et pour apporter
Christ à la personne
dans une culture
qui est de plus en plus
hostile aux chrétiens
et à l'évangile
nos amis
nos voisins
et même nos ennemis
non chrétiens
ont besoin de notre amour
et non de notre peur
même s'ils ne perçoivent
pas leurs besoins
est-ce qu'il y a
un non-croyant
avec qui vous avez besoin
de partager l'évangile
une des choses
si nous avons la possibilité
s'il n'est pas de passage
si nous ne le croisons pas
dans la rue
mais qui peut être
notre voisin
notre collègue
nous devons d'abord
commencer à vivre
une vie d'amour
et de sollicitude
envers lui
comme le Christ
nous a aimés
alors dans cette catégorie
l'autre catégorie
nous continuons
avec les catégories
de personnes
que nous devons aimer
notre prochain
Matthieu 22
verset 39
je donne la référence
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
nous dit
aime ton prochain
comme toi-même
comme le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
l'enseigne dans la parabole
du bon samaritain
donc là c'est encore
Ed Welch qui parle
il s'agit d'une catégorie
fourre-tout
il n'existe aucune limite
d'âge
quand on parle
de notre prochain
on inclut
n'importe quelle limite
d'âge
même des enfants
parce qu'aujourd'hui
on est dans une société
qui est en plus de deux autres
même le bruit des enfants
devient un problème
pour certains
donc si tu aimes ton prochain
ton coeur ne va pas
se durcir
quand tu entends
un enfant
qui est peut-être
en train de faire
du bruit pendant le culte
il n'existe aucune limite
d'âge
d'origine ethnique
socio-économique
politique
personnelle
ou autre
pour qui nous sommes
censés aimer
notre prochain
quelle que soit
la catégorie
à laquelle
appartient notre prochain
nous lui devons
de l'amour
une autre catégorie
que nous devons aimer
nos familles physiques
c'est dans le contexte
familial
que nous apprenons
à manifester
de l'amour
et de l'attention
et c'est pour ça aussi
que Dieu a permis cela
et c'est souvent
dans ce contexte
que nous rencontrons
le plus de difficultés
à manifester
un amour véritable
ça c'est
à cause de la dureté
de nos coeurs
et
des frères et sœurs
donc là je vais parler
de la famille physique
là je vais parler
des frères et sœurs
de l'église
le nouveau testament
est riche
en explications
sur la façon
dont nous devons
nous comporter
avec la famille
de Dieu
dans Galates 6
verset 10
l'apôtre Paul nous dit
ainsi donc
pendant que nous en avons
l'occasion
pratiquons le bien
envers tous
et principalement
envers les frères
en la foi
l'un des meilleurs
outils d'évangélisation
surtout pour les gens
qui vont nous voir
un moment vivre ensemble
l'un des meilleurs
outils d'évangélisation
dont nous disposons
est l'amour fraternel
quand vous avez un invité
qui vient au culte
et qui regarde
avant le culte
pendant le culte
après le culte
comment nous sommes
en train de manifester
l'amour fraternel
c'est quelque chose
qui touche
d'ailleurs ça a été
une des choses
qui m'a beaucoup marqué
quand j'ai rencontré
des chrétiens authentiques
c'était de voir
la communion fraternelle
qui avait entre eux
ça m'a beaucoup choqué
je n'avais jamais vu
cet amour là
pour nous chrétiens
de plus en plus
l'amour devrait régner
dans nos relations
et là encore
Welch
on parle beaucoup
ce soir
je crois même
c'est la
donc il disait
j'ai discuté
avec de nombreuses personnes
désireuses de connaître
leur don spirituel
j'ai l'impression
que cette perspective
témoigne d'une rupture
au sein de l'église
elle reflète une église
où nous nous déplaçons
en tant qu'individus
épanouis
plutôt que de nous unir
en une communauté
glorifiant Dieu
et pour beaucoup
de personnes
elles vont se concentrer
sur ce qu'il y a à faire
plutôt que de vivre
l'amour
au sein de l'église
l'église est le lieu
où nous devrions
démontrer au monde
qui nous observe
ce que signifie
vivre dans l'amour
et non dans la peur
donc rappelons-nous
toujours que nous sommes
en train d'exprimer
comment ne pas vivre
dans une peur
et une crainte de l'homme
quelle forme
et donc pour aborder
ce point
donc ça va être
le troisième point
donc nous voyons
nous devons réorienter
pour nous être délivrés
de la crainte de l'homme
et pouvoir avoir
cette crainte de Dieu
nous devons la réorienter
nous devons réorienter
notre crainte vers Dieu
nous devons redéfinir
comment nous sommes en train
d'apprécier notre relation
à l'homme
envers l'homme
et maintenant
nous allons réfléchir
quelle forme prend cet amour
et ce service
1 Corinthiens 13
est l'un des meilleurs textes
pour comprendre la forme
que notre amour
et notre service
devraient prendre
envers les autres
d'ailleurs je pense que
c'est l'un des textes
pour tous ceux qui ont assisté
à des mariages
à un moment
c'était pratiquement
le texte des mariages
même s'il est pris
un peu à tort
nous allons
donc
là j'avais pas
1 Corinthiens 13
3 à 7
nous dit
et quand je distribuerai
tous mes biens
pour la nourriture
des pauvres
quand je livrerai
même mon corps
pour être brûlé
si je n'ai pas la charité
cela ne me sert de rien
la charité est patiente
elle est pleine de bonté
la charité n'est point envieuse
la charité ne se vante point
elle ne s'enfle point d'orgueil
elle ne fait rien de malhonnête
elle ne cherche point son intérêt
elle ne s'irrite point
elle ne soupçonne point le mal
elle ne se réjouit point de l'injustice
mais elle se réjouit de la vérité
elle excuse tout
elle croit tout
elle espère tout
elle supporte tout
nous pouvons
commencer à réfléchir
à cette description de l'amour
rappelons-nous
c'est un texte que nous connaissons
beaucoup dans nos églises
réfléchissons
par rapport à ce point
ça c'est un des aspects
déjà très pratiques
si vous vous asseyez
là
sur ces prochains jours
et que vous décidez
de revoir ces points pratiques
et de vous demander
si vous êtes vraiment
en train d'appliquer cet amour
envers toutes les différentes catégories
dont nous avons parlé
envers Dieu déjà
envers le non-croyant
envers le prochain
envers les frères et soeurs Christ
notez ces choses
faites cet examen
priez pour cela
et c'est même bien
de pouvoir échanger
avec les frères et soeurs
aussi à un moment
si vous avez du mal
à pouvoir aimer
votre prochain
ou à aimer
même à pouvoir aimer
l'amour des frères et soeurs
c'est important aussi
d'échanger même
avec des frères et soeurs
en Christ
c'est même de pouvoir
prier aussi sur ces choses-là
de réfléchir
comment ces choses
peuvent être vécues
au niveau de l'église
si vous êtes membre
de l'église EBN
et je pense là
c'est le cas
pour une grande majorité
pensez à l'alliance
que nous avons conclue
envers les uns
envers les autres
d'ailleurs
c'est même un rappel
souvent
je dis souvent
que quand on traite
certains cas
j'ai l'impression
que beaucoup
ont oublié
l'alliance
que nous répétons toujours
alors de l'assemblée générale
nous répétons
nous répétons le texte
ensemble
chaque assemblée générale
avant chaque baptême
nous répétons
et souvent
il est nécessaire
avant même
n'attendez pas
l'assemblée générale
pour pouvoir relire
pour pouvoir méditer
sur cet aspect
donc si nous sommes
membres de l'église
nous pouvons
repenser à l'alliance
que nous avons conclue
les uns envers les autres
cette alliance
qui nous engage
à nous aimer
et à prendre soin
les uns des autres
dans le cadre de l'église
alors ça je rappelle un peu
nous marcherons ensemble
dans l'amour fraternel
comme cela convient
aux membres
d'une église chrétienne
nous nous porterons
mutuellement
une attention
et une vigilance
affectueuse
c'est pas
c'est voilà
c'est
on va dire
parallèlement
c'est la même chose
et nous nous exhorterons
et nous nous supplirons
fidèlement
les uns les autres
selon les besoins
nous nous réjouirons
du bonheur
de chacun
et nous nous efforcerons
de supporter
avec tendresse
et sympathie
nos fardeaux
et nos peines
je pense que ça dit quelque chose
ça vous dit quelque chose ?
voilà
c'est l'alliance
de membres
que nous répétons
souvent
et ce que j'aimerais dire
là sur cet aspect
de quelle forme
prend cet amour
et ce service
nous aimons
parce que Dieu
nous a aimés en premier
rappelez-vous
ce que j'ai dit au début
nous n'aimons pas
parce que nous avons
choisi d'aimer
selon nos préférences
nous aimons
parce que Dieu
nous a aimés en premier
donc les contours
de l'amour du chrétien
pour son prochain
sont soigneusement
et entièrement façonnés
par l'amour du Christ
pour nous
souvenez-vous de ça
c'est l'amour de Christ
pour moi
qui détermine
comment j'aime les autres
et quand je réalise
comme bien
et profond
et je n'ai même pas
de mots pour désigner
l'amour de Christ
pour moi
alors je comprends
un moment
que je vais pouvoir
être au repos
pour pouvoir aimer les autres
alors sur cet aspect
comment développer
un véritable coeur
de serviteur
comment nous pouvons
cultiver un coeur
d'amour
à quoi peut ressembler
l'amour
au lieu de la peur
puisque nous sommes
en train de parler
de comment être délivré
de la crainte des hommes
nous sommes appelés
nous en tant que croyants
à des vies
des relations
harmonieuses
nous ne sommes pas appelés
à vivre des relations
chaotiques
nous ne sommes pas appelés
à nous disputer
tout le temps
nous ne sommes pas appelés
à vivre isolés
aimer et servir
les autres implique
de nous impliquer
dans leur vie
même si cela peut être
difficile et gênant
donc sur cet aspect
de comment nous pouvons
développer un véritable
coeur de serviteur
comment nous pouvons
cultiver un coeur d'amour
dans ce sens
nous devons réfléchir
à notre motivation
donc le premier point
c'est de réfléchir
à notre motivation
même lorsqu'il s'agit
d'aimer
et de servir les autres
même dans notre désir
d'aimer les autres
notre désir d'aimer
peut parfois naître
du désir d'être aimé
comment nous pouvons
le savoir
si même ce désir
d'aimer les autres
vient d'abord
du désir
d'être aimé
quelle est votre réaction
lorsque quelqu'un
ne répond pas
à votre amour
comme vous le souhaiteriez
lorsque vous faites preuve
d'amour
envers quelqu'un
et qu'il répond
par l'indifférence
ou pire
par la colère
quelle est votre réaction
si vous avez
des attentes claires
quant à la façon
dont vous souhaitez
qu'une personne
réponde à votre amour
si elle ne réagit pas
de cette manière
et que vous vous sentez
dévasté
il y a un problème
ça veut dire un moment
que vous êtes en train
d'aimer
avec le but
de recevoir quelque chose
il y a de fortes chances
alors qu'on n'agisse
pas principalement
par un amour sincère
pour les personnes
l'amour sincère
c'est qu'un moment
c'est difficile à dire
comme ça
si dimanche
je dis bonjour
à deux ou trois personnes
et qu'elles ne me répondent pas
je vais rendre grâce à Dieu
je ne vais pas commencer
à m'irriter
ou on ne me verra pas
le dimanche prochain
au contraire
je vois qu'il y a peut-être
un besoin d'amour
et ce que je vais faire
c'est de continuer
à dire bonjour
jusqu'à ce que ces personnes
me répondent
et me disent bonjour
je vais continuer
à sourire
jusqu'à ce que ces personnes
qui étaient indifférentes
à mon sourire
finissent par sourire
et apprécier
souvent beaucoup de personnes
n'ont pas compris
souvent que Dieu
les place
là pour un but
et souvent quand elles
voient que ces choses
ne vont pas dans le sens
où elles aimeraient
pour pouvoir être satisfaites
elles partent
donc nous devons d'abord
réfléchir à notre motivation
lorsqu'il s'agit d'aimer
et de servir les autres
notre motivation
doit trouver sa joie en Christ
et donc si les gens
ne m'ont pas dit bonjour
ce n'est pas pour autant
la fin du monde
je vais rendre grâce à Dieu
et je vais voir comment
je peux manifester
encore plus d'amour
la deuxième chose
c'est de regarder au Christ
Philippiens 2
verset 3 à 7
c'est très important
que nous puissions lire
ces passages
Philippiens 2
verset 3 à 7
nous dit
étudions la vie du Seigneur Jésus-Christ
remarquons comment
notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ
a aimé et servi les autres
c'est très important
quand nous considérons
comment le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
s'est humilié
pour aimer les autres
pour nous aimer
nous sommes sans excuse
dans nos relations avec autrui
nous sommes en train de parler
du Dieu de l'univers
qui s'est dépouillé
de toute sa gloire céleste
dont nous n'avons même pas idée
pour même naître pauvre
naître dans une étable
ça va nous parler encore en ce moment
les déficits budgétaires sont mauvais
comme nous pouvons être en train
de le constater au niveau de la France
mais les déficits d'amour
sont des choses à corriger
Welsch dit
quand le royaume de Dieu
règne dans nos cœurs
nous aspirons plus à servir
qu'à être servi
nous aspirons plus à être
à honorer
plus qu'à être honoré
à aimer
plus à
plus qu'à être aimé
cela ne signifie pas
que nous ne nous soucions pas
d'être aimé
cela signifie simplement
que nous voulons toujours
surpasser les autres
en amour
est-ce que nous courons toujours
le risque
est-ce que nous courons le risque
d'une relation déséquilibrée
quand je vous parle de cet exemple
où je suis en train de forcer
je suis en train de continuer
à manifester de l'amour
même si les personnes
ne répondent pas
oui
mais telle est notre relation
avec Dieu
Dieu nous aime
toujours le premier
il nous aime plus
Dieu fait toujours
le premier pas
Dieu affiche toujours
son affection
débordante envers nous
si nous regardons
à la façon dont Dieu nous aime
nous allons réaliser
que de la même façon
que nous pouvons constater
des gens à qui nous disons
bonjour
qui ne répondent pas
chaque fois que nous péchons
c'est cette façon
que nous sommes en train
de faire avec Dieu
Dieu est en train
de manifester de l'amour
nous sommes en train
de nous mettre en retrait
à cause de notre péché
nous sommes en train
de ne pas répondre
à cause du péché
mais pourtant
qu'est-ce que Dieu fait
il continue à faire le pas
envers nous
donc ça c'est
regarder à Jésus
c'est de réaliser
un moment
que notre Seigneur
a toujours
notre Seigneur
s'est dépouillé
de sa gloire
pour faire le premier pas
envers nous
notre Seigneur
s'est dépouillé
de sa gloire
et continue de nous aimer
d'un amour
qui dépasse
notre entendement
le troisième point
c'est d'apprendre
à prier régulièrement
pour
d'apprendre à prier
régulièrement
pour les autres
c'est d'apprendre
à prier
pour leur relation
avec Dieu
c'est de prier
pour que le Seigneur
nous donne à nous
un cœur plein d'amour
pour eux
et de prier
pour qu'il hôte
un cœur
qui est emprunt
de peur
et que nous
puissions encourager
les autres à prier
pour que nous
puissions nous aimer
vraiment les uns
les autres
si
je parle
si comme moi
il vous est arrivé
de ne pas aimer
les autres
confessez à Dieu
et aux autres
que vous n'aimez pas
comme vous le devriez
le quatrième point
sur cette façon
de pouvoir avoir
cette façon
d'aimer
c'est de réfléchir
à des façons concrètes
de servir
les autres
parce qu'on peut dire
à un moment
qu'on aime
et d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça
qu'on va dire
à un moment
mais
s'il n'y a pas
de preuve
de l'amour
et que ça vient
juste des lèvres
comment on va dire
qu'on aime
donc nous devons
nous organiser
pour le bien
des autres
nous devons réfléchir
à la manière
dont nous pouvons
servir les autres
avec amour
cela fera du bien
à notre âme
et à l'inverse
cela combattra
même notre orgueil
lorsque nous commençons
à aimer les autres
plutôt qu'à les craindre
nous voyons
de véritables fruits
qui sont produits
par Dieu
et quand on parle
des fruits
qui sont produits
par Dieu
on va justement
aborder
le dernier point
qui est lié à ça
qui est lié à ce cours
quels sont les résultats
de l'amour
comment nous devons voir
les résultats
de l'amour
et du service
plutôt que de la peur
et du besoin
donc j'ai parlé
des fruits
que produise
notre crainte de Dieu
notre amour
pour les autres
et là nous allons
aborder
quels sont les résultats
de l'amour
et du service
lorsque nous choisissons
de rejeter la peur
ou le fait
de craindre l'homme
par besoin
le premier résultat
c'est l'unité
en cherchant à aimer
et à servir
en évitant
l'amour
qui est basé
sur le besoin
de l'autre
en évitant la peur
nous pouvons rechercher
et vivre l'unité
qui devrait se manifester
dans le corps du Christ
l'unité ne signifie pas
seulement s'entendre
mais l'unité
signifie de vivre
de manière
à être tous
centrés
avant tout
sur le Christ
en fixant collectivement
notre regard
sur Jésus
nous trouvons l'unité
les uns
avec les autres
c'est un point
qui est très important
lorsque je suis en train
de nettoyer la salle
et qu'il y a des gens
qui continuent peut-être
à causer
et que j'aimerais
qu'ils partent
et que je ne vais pas
me fâcher contre eux
c'est parce qu'à un moment
je suis en train
de comprendre
un moment
que je suis d'abord
en train d'honorer
le Christ
je vais leur demander
de partir
mais ça ne va pas
être un point de colère
pour moi
je me souviens
quand j'étais en Afrique
le frère qui était
avec nous
le responsable du ménage
nous disait
si tu rejoins
l'équipe de ménage
si tu comptes
un jour
murmurer
ou boudé
ne rejoins pas l'équipe
donc ça veut dire
que du moment
où tu es dans l'équipe
tu ne te plaindras pas
tu feras le service
avec joie
quelle que soit
la façon
dont les gens
vont se comporter
donc à un moment
nous
et pourquoi il disait ça
ça veut dire
qu'à un moment
je fixe mes regards
sur Christ
je ne fixe pas mes regards
sur ce que l'homme
peut me faire
donc en fixant
collectivement
donc les résultats
de l'amour
et du service
ça produit l'unité
c'est en fixant
collectivement
notre regard sur Jésus
nous trouvons l'unité
les uns avec les autres
il est impossible
d'aborder
nos relations
horizontales
sans avoir établi
une perspective
relationnelle
verticale appropriée
donc si nous
nous basons d'abord
sur les relations
horizontales
avec les hommes
pour pouvoir
chercher l'unité
et l'amour
nous n'arriverons
jamais à ça
la première chose
c'est d'abord
cette relation
verticale
avec Dieu
c'est de nous remplir
de l'amour de Dieu
c'est de prier
pour que Dieu
me remplisse mon coeur
de son amour
pour que cet amour
soit déversé
tout au long
de la journée
et je vais dire
spécialement le dimanche
prie le dimanche
pour que ton coeur
soit rempli d'amour
pour que tu ne ressortes
pas frustré
du culte
à cause de
non
ton regard
est fixé sur Christ
le deuxième point
des résultats
de l'amour
du service
c'est le respect
et l'appréciation
sincère des autres
en grandissant
dans l'amour
des autres
nous apprenons
à les connaître
plus profondément
il est intéressant
de constater
que nous craignons
souvent ceux
que nous ne connaissons
pas vraiment
c'est même souvent
ce qu'on va dire
c'est la crainte
de l'autre
qui va produire
la peur
en cherchant
à aimer les autres
de manière spécifique
à les connaître
plus profondément
pour mieux les servir
en sortant
de notre égoïsme
et de notre
autoprotection
nous commençons
à les percevoir
sous un jour
profondément nouveau
nous réalisons
qu'au lieu
d'adorer les autres
comme de faux dieux
ou des idoles
nous commençons
à voir
comment ils portent
l'image de Dieu
nous commençons
à voir les autres
comme des porteurs
distincts
de l'image de Dieu
que nous sommes appelés
à aimer
et à prendre soin
comme le Christ
nous a aimés
nous portons
l'image distincte
de Dieu
et dans l'unité
nous portons
une image
unitaire
du Christ
qui est affichée
au monde
la troisième
chose que ça produit
et ce n'est pas
un mensonge
tous ceux qui ont
vécu cette expérimentation
d'aimer son prochain
et de ne plus
se centrer sur soi
mais d'aimer son prochain
nous allons
trouver de la paix
nous allons trouver
de la joie
et même lorsque nous allons
faire un bilan
de notre vie
on va même se dire
est-ce que c'est ça
souvent beaucoup de personnes
parlent mais quand on arrive
à un certain bilan
de notre vie
c'est de voir
combien j'ai pu être utile
aux autres
comment j'ai pu aimer
les autres
et là aussi
un des résultats
je dis plusieurs résultats
qui sont donnés
lorsque nous choisissons
d'aimer et servir
c'est que nous allons
trouver de la paix
nous allons trouver
de la joie
de la patience
de la douceur
nous allons trouver
ce qui caractérise
ce qu'on appelle
le fruit de l'esprit
donc là j'ai donné
quelques éléments
quand nous vivons
dans la crainte du seigneur
et non la crainte des hommes
nous commençons
à mieux comprendre
ce que signifie
être soumis
à l'esprit de Dieu
et donc
en conclusion
donc là je vais
conclure
je vais conclure
l'ensemble
de cette série
sur la crainte de Dieu
même la peur
de l'homme
en conclusion
est-ce que nous devons
craindre Dieu
simplement pour le craindre
et est-ce que nous devons
aimer les autres
simplement pour les aimer
non
il y a des choses
plus importantes
qui sont en jeu
la gloire de Dieu
est en jeu
Dieu nous a créé
pour le connaître
et l'adorer
comme le roi majestueux
comme le seigneur de gloire
il nous a créé
pour le connaître
comme le seul vrai Dieu
et sauveur
de tous les hommes
ainsi
lorsque nous le craignons
nous manifestons
la grandeur
insurpassable
de Dieu
nous manifestons
son excellence
suprême
Dieu est glorifié
lorsque nous le craignons
à juste titre
comme lorsque nous
pouvons être en train
je pense
pour une idée
aller sur
une haute montagne
et regarder
l'horizon
vous êtes remplis
d'admiration
et vous allez un peu
comprendre aussi
ce sens
de gloire
d'excellence
ce sens
où nous
nous sommes en train
de voir la gloire
de Dieu
et de comprendre
un moment
que ce sont des choses
qui dépassent
notre entendement
le commandement
le temps que le Seigneur
Jésus-Christ
donnait un moment
il va dire un moment
aimez-vous les uns
les autres
comme je vous ai aimé
vous aussi
aimez-vous les uns
les autres
à ceux-ci
tous connaîtront
que vous êtes
mes disciples
le témoignage public
de notre amour
lorsque nous choisissons
de ne pas craindre
les hommes
lorsque nous choisissons
un moment
de faire confiance
à Dieu
là je reviens
sur ce qui a été dit
à partir des psaumes
par exemple
ça nous encourage
à la crainte de Dieu
lorsque nous choisissons
de placer notre confiance
en Dieu
et non dans la crainte
des hommes
le témoignage public
de notre amour
les uns pour les autres
sera la confirmation
de tout ce pourquoi
Jésus
mérite de vivre
et d'être glorifié
nous sommes en train
de réaliser
qu'aujourd'hui
si nous sommes encore
sur cette terre
nous sommes là
pour manifester
l'amour de Dieu
aussi bien dans la communion
fraternelle que nous vivons
que dans l'annonce
de l'évangile
et donc vous voyez
que même l'annonce
de l'évangile
est une manifestation
de l'amour
pour notre prochain
mais si nous avons
honte de Dieu
nous avons honte
de l'évangile
nous sommes en train
d'être dans la crainte
des hommes
mais lorsque nous sommes
en train de comprendre
que notre Dieu
mérite d'être glorifié
à cause de ce qu'il est
alors nous n'avons pas peur
d'annoncer l'évangile
alors en tant que chrétien
nous ne devons pas être là
donc fatigués
de faire le bien
nous ne devons pas
nous décourager
de faire le bien
nous devons réaliser
que chaque fois
que nous sommes en train
de servir
en ayant les yeux fixés
sur Christ
lorsque nous sommes en train
d'aimer et de servir
en ayant les yeux fixés
sur Christ
notre travail
est en train d'honorer
le Christ
et est en train
d'apporter
de la renommée
à son nom
nous sommes en train
de glorifier le Christ
et la gloire de Christ
est en train d'être affichée
au sein des nations
gloire Dieu
et la gloire de Christ
est en train d'être affichée